good morning welcome back to another
saturday morning vfx adventure guys
we are we're going to be doing some
really cool stuff today i'm very excited
and um you know i'll probably say this a
couple times while people filter in but
i want to give you guys a quick
overview of what we got in store on
today's
stream all right so as you guys know
we're doing the parallel dimensions
contest
it's an environment 3d environment
contest
that i've been doing over the last month
with nvidia and pny
we're doing some awesome giveaways but
basically on today's stream what i'm
focusing on here
is basically taking this mountain that
you see here on the bottom right
you know it's a very plain basic
mountain i hadn't even touched it yet
it's just kind of a default
default mountain here inside of cinema
4d and we're going to turn it into
this amazing volcano that you see before
you right here we're going to talk about
first um giving a rocky texture that
we're happy with
um and then we're going to add some of
these like
foreground well i guess they're it's all
in the background but we're going to add
these like craggy little
extra bits of mountain that surround the
volcano
and then what we're going to do is we're
going to
work on this shader probably with an
emissive in octane
but we're going to get this lava flow
look going down
the volcano and then finally what we're
gonna do is if you look in the crevices
of this
volcano you can see um
my cat gilbert is like stomping all
around
the computer here hey bud now's not a
good time
now's not a good time so
we're gonna basically and you can tell
he eats this thing
like my mic cover is is basically
covered in little gilbert chops
but lastly what we're gonna do is we're
going to talk about how to add these
like animated
steam jets um coming out from
the the belly of this volcano and we're
gonna
you know use after effects and some
animated png sequences to do that
so i'm very excited to hop in with you
guys and make this
make this thing look super awesome um
so okay couple more things couple more
things i have to write all this stuff
down because
it's a lot um next for those of you guys
who don't know
i'm doing a render contest it's a 3d
environment contest and what you're
looking at here is actually what
i created on the first stream um
two streams ago this is concept art
that's going to
guide my 3d rendering as you guys can
see here this is what we created
last week all right so this was week one
with concept art
and week two was creating the the ground
getting a realistic looking ground and
if i come in here
if i get a little closer you can really
see like
you know we spent a lot of time getting
this mud looking right and breaking up
the mud and different reflections and i
can still tweak this i probably
still will but not on today's stream um
we're focusing on the volcano
all right so if you guys hadn't seen
those last two streams definitely
definitely do so
um you know hang out with me for the for
the day today here for the next few
hours
and if you hadn't started if you hadn't
joined this contest
it is not too late it is it is not too
late at all
um it's called parallel dimensions
because what i'm going to do is i'm
asking all you guys to create some
awesome environment
using this template of this character
who's walking
toward this mountain everybody's got
this template you can download it
the link is in the description it'll
bring you to this page right here
so like i said i'm working with nvidia
and pny
to do this with you guys and they're
giving out some super awesome prizes too
so basically you know this is just a
brief description of who i am
what i do um you know i don't want to
get into that i don't need to get into
that right now but parallel dimensions
basically is this contest that we're
doing together you can download the
template right here
you can enter as well you have both
streams
right here this is basically a place
this is the landing page where all the
info
is going to be added and your guys's
submissions as they come in and i've
already got the first like five or six
submissions
we're going to be adding them to this
page as well so this will be a place for
you guys to track that
again this is what we created last week
all right and as far as prizes go um
nvidia
they hooked me up with a quadro and it
really is incredible
i truly do love it it stands out to me
in ways other cards have not um
but the first place prize for you guys
whoever wins this render challenge gets
the quadro
in rtx 4k um second place you guys get
an nvidia shield tv pro
third place a one terabyte ssd
which is super crucial for working
quickly
and fourth and place honorable mentions
are going to get a 256 gigabyte
flash drive all right um now
you can only win these prizes if you
have a us
shipping address and you are a us
citizen
apologies to my international folks who
will be submitting you can still submit
you can still join
i just can't ship these prizes out to
you it has to do with
some legal stuff on their end um it's a
bit complicated and i do apologize
so if you are international and you do
win as well i do want to send you guys
one of my prints um i do have
a a print website
where you know i have all my photography
and you guys can buy different prints
um you know i'm running a 15 off sale
right now but for those of you
international folks who win this thing
like i definitely want to make it worth
your while um and i'm gonna be sending
you a super nice print
you know signed by myself i got a note
on the back and got some
really nice music recommendations that
fits the piece of art that i'll be
sending your way so
um definitely wanted to make that right
with you guys now
the contest does end on november 2nd
that is the last time
um you guys have to upload and right at
the end here right at the bottom of this
landing page
you'll see you know you got 8 days 14
hours it goes
it goes down to the second here okay so
make sure you guys upload
right in here and yeah i think
anything else um yeah we talked about
faqs deadline
um you know at the beginning of the
second stream
so last week's stream i did a whole
bunch of faqs and if you guys aren't a
part of
my create with clint discord server
i do have a parallel dimensions like
section there
where there's faqs you can read all the
faqs there and i'll be adding to them
as you guys have good questions
so shall we jump in everybody
how's everybody doing here let me let me
check in with y'all
thank you for joining everybody really
appreciate y'all
i'm excited to jump in today do this
volcano make it look super nice ooh let
me grab my coffee
one moment
all right
what are my chrome extensions i got dark
mode
dark mode it's the way to go i wake up
really early so
usually i'm not on my computer when i
wake up super early but i eventually do
get on my computer around seven o'clock
and i don't want to blast my eyeballs
with white with a white screen so dark
mode is very handy
what's up everybody i'm glad that you
guys are working on your submissions
um if anyone here is working on their
submissions
or is still planning to enter give me a
thumbs up all right i'm very excited for
all the stuff
that's going to come together for this
and at the end of the day i'm going to
choose
the top 20 best renders on on the
november 7th stream
i'm choosing the top 20 okay and i'm
going to put them together into a super
cool audio visual montage
um that's it's really going to showcase
all of your guys's hard work so the
harder you work on this
the better that final end product will
be i'm going to post it on my channel
here
i'm going to blast it out and video is
going to blast it out pny is going to
blast it out
so it'll be a really cool chance to get
some awesome exposure and win some cool
prizes
all right
so how are we going to do this volcano i
think the first things first
we need to find a texture that that
really works for this
for this mountain in the background it's
going to be kind of foggy so
i don't think we need to do anything too
crazy right
um like we don't need any we don't even
need 4k
textures i think a 1k or a 2k texture
will totally be fine
we don't need displacement or anything
like that um
because it's so far away we need to save
as much of our computer
computing power um for for the whole
scene everything's going to build up
really fast alright so we don't want to
waste it where
we don't need to use it okay so i think
the first thing i'll do
um
you know i'll probably hop over to
bridge
qixel bridge now the foreground texture
you're seeing here
this is rd textures real displacement
textures and they're the best
textures i've ever used
they come in 4k and 8k sizes but let me
just browse
um qxel bridge real quick to see if they
have anything that will work for us
so i'm going to go to surfaces and we'll
go to
rock and i think jagged would be nice
so we probably want to mix
a few different textures together in
order to get
a more unique kind of look okay
so we certainly want everything to be
um oh icelandic quarry rock that's not
bad
layered cliff rock this is pretty good
so i'm gonna start favoriting these
as i see ones that i that i like that i
think will work for us
this is a good one um i saw one up top
here that's
actually not bad the coal mine wall is
pretty good
and we just want a little bit of texture
differentiate
uh differentiation i think that's the
word
um in these three that we choose and
we'll mix them together it might just be
two
so let me start with this and we will
we'll go from there basically right so
let me download this
you definitely want to download the 8k
versions
because why not you know
so i'll download that guy and let's go
ahead
and download this coal mine wall as well
download and we'll export just the 2k
is like way back in there it's hilarious
he's having a hoot
um all right so these are doing their
thing
basically we'll mix those together in
order to get
this kind of look here this rocky look
okay
and then we're going to come in here and
we're probably going to select some of
these polygons and make an emissive
texture
two different emissive textures that
will break up with
a basically some octane noise
one of them will be this red and one
will be this bright white
orangish yellow gilbert what are you
doing bud what are you messing with down
there
hey
all right
sweet i'm excited to see how
you know this animated png sequence will
really work with these like
little steam vents inside of the volcano
i think that's gonna look super cool
what's up everybody thanks for joining
thanks for hopping in
good to see everybody here today
yeah at 5 million subscribers i watch
all of the mcu movies
with you guys we'll do it we'll do a
live a live viewing of that
look at this little bud this little
gilbert just down here what's up gilbert
hey bud he's romping around he's having
a good time
all right let's check our downloads yeah
sweet so both of those finished
we'll go ahead and export check our
export settings 2k that's perfect
let's grab both of these
uh what just happened one and two oh
come on
so export coal mine wall and then we'll
hop in here and we'll export
the second one boom the layered cliff
rock
2k as well you guys have seen me use
quixl bridge before it is the best it's
the easiest way to transfer models
to the program to your program of choice
it works with everything it works with
um with unreal
with uh with maya with blender with
arnold with
basically any any renderer that you have
like you're going to be able to make use
of that
so it it dropped these two materials
down here in the bottom left my head's
covering it but
you know they look like these they're
there
so let me hop out of camera view and
let's get really close to this mountain
and just real quick like see what we're
doing
okay so i'm right up on this mountain
and i'm just gonna go ahead and drop our
first material
onto the mountain and see what we get it
looks horrible
absolutely horrible maybe from a
distance
it could look kind of cool that's
actually not
half bad it really is not half bad
the fog is gonna help us break up
you know um how dark that is but i'll
also color correct
it as well but we need to do a couple
things just to make sure that this is
being
wrapped around this mountain
in the correct way okay so i'll hop out
of the camera we'll get up in here
we'll take a look at what we're looking
at let's double click and go in
to the node viewer if you're not working
in the node viewer
basically any program has it any
renderer has it you should be in the
node viewer it's a lot easier to see all
the things that
are making up your texture or your your
shader versus you know
diving through menu trees and whatnot
so let's go ahead and add a projection
node to all this
you guys have seen me do this a million
times before
and i really wish octane had a way of
dishing out this projection node
to all the different image textures in
one go
that'd be super nice
all right let's set that to box okay and
that's going to be able that's going to
wrap the texture around this mountain
in a more uniform way it's obviously
way too tiny so we need to scale it up
by maybe a hundred times
and now we're getting something that
looks a bit more uniform and a bit more
correct
it looks really cool
let's just roll with that let's say
that's looking good for now let's set up
our second one okay so we're going to do
the same thing
let's apply that coal wall to the
mountain all right
and let's change the projection
so we'll add that projection node and
pipe it in
to all the different image textures that
make up
this mega scans texture and it's great
because
the mega scan textures that's the whole
point of this is they come
pre-built they're already built for you
and you guys know too
that basically the black and white image
textures
they only need to be recognized as black
and white versus color
so the type is set to float by default
in these materials it's really nice i
think for some reason the specular isn't
set to float
it should be
but yeah that's just an incredible quick
way to get your textures going
in your program all right let's set up
the box
it's going to be way too tiny and we'll
make it 100 times bigger
and it's pretty cool that's looking
pretty cool it's like jet black
that's fun okay so one way
we can do this one way we can break up
these different materials
is definitely with a a mixed material
we're going to want to do that so let's
go ahead and save your work make sure
you guys are always saving
and if you're doing it the christmas way
the rocket lasso away
we're going to be saving iterations so
i'm on f
let's go to g and basically as you make
progress you're saving out a new version
so you can always go back you know you
can always make tweaks and it'll be cool
to document the process too
all right so that's that's looking
freaking sweet like that's like that's a
really nice texture
and if i hop back and view it through
the camera it's very dark so we'll
probably need to come up
um on the brightness with that and i
think
as we go the lighting and everything
will kind of bring itself around
and come together as we continue working
and yeah so you guys are asking
questions about the character
gilbert hey bud
so jamir you say can we use a different
rig but use the same animation
um by rig you mean a different character
you can change out the skin you can use
a different character skin
you're really trying to get out aren't
you
but you cannot change the the animation
you cannot change the bones um the
character needs to move and walk
like this character is moving and
walking definitely change out the way
the character looks
believe the way he's walking okay he or
she
it's kind of nondescript um because the
whole point is i want to blend all of
your guys's renders together
and have them look like they're looping
together
then you can't do that if you change out
the walk cycle
all right so let's go ahead and make a
mix material
and we'll add
both of these rock textures to that
mixed material okay
and we'll add that mix material to
our mountain
and that's going to be a perfect 50 50
half and half
split between both materials and god
dang it this thing
always crashes every time i open up a
mixed material
in uh in octane every time
i knew it was gonna happen too that's
why i made it make sure to save
jeez it's like it's relentless
but i've never made a volcano before i'm
super excited to
to see how we create this volcano
starting from a
base default you know kind of material
in cinema 4d and bringing it out to
something that looks like this
this is of course mount mount doom
in mordor
come on cinema
all right
full spectrum studios all right you say
i get crashes every time i do the mix
material that way if you do it inside of
the node editor it doesn't crash
let's give it a shot
so let's go ahead and grab a mix
material
boom all right we're going to say
material 1 is this rock
and then we bring in material number
two the coal mine layer
will go ahead and shift-click
that and it'll bring in the whole the
whole hierarchy all right material 2
fantastic and then let's go ahead and
apply that
to our mountain
give it a quick render
so now this is mixing between both
textures by 50 50. so
so it's set to 0.5 if i go to zero we'll
go to one texture
if i go to one it'll go to the other
texture point five is right
smack dab in the middle but what i want
to do is break this up
last time we used noise all right we use
the
octane noise to break it up but let me
try a falloff map
let's try fall off and see see what that
does
so by default it's actually pretty sweet
what a falloff is doing if i solo it
okay
it's not really doing much um
[Music]
i figure the easiest way to show you
what's happening
let's just take two rgb spectrums and
we'll say that this rock cliff layer
will pipe that into the albedo which is
the color
and we'll color it yeah it looks like
it's set to white
okay and then let's do black for this
other one
we'll set that to black
so you can get an idea of how this fall
off map is breaking up these two
textures okay
so with this one i think it's basically
saying anything that is facing
the no anything that's on the outside of
the model
is going to be a certain texture that's
what normal versus
irae is that's by default now if we
select the falloff node and we change it
to
the 90 degree option what that's gonna
do
i believe is say anything that's
up top is gonna be a certain
look anything that's at the bottom is
going to be another look
and finally we have the 180 degree
option
which i feel like is the
opposite but we don't want that one we
want the 90 degree one that goes from
top to bottom
i think that'll be a cool look so let's
change that back we'll go 90 degree and
let's go ahead and
maybe the skew factor we can adjust
that's just how much of one we see
versus the other kind of crunches it
and what you can also do is give it a
a gradient and you can crunch that
gradient down
to really show more of one or less of
the other right so
it's just like levels in after effects
or photoshop
you're kind of just crunching that that
layer down
but we'll leave it as uh by default
right
so go ahead and we'll pipe back in the
actual color
and reload our scene
d von williams what up devon
dude devon is one of my very best
friends one of my very very best friends
um devon so i'm doing this render and it
kind of looks like a death stranding
render
i'm like pretty inspired by it um
and dude i set up the model you got me
for
my birthday uh let me let me show you
guys real quick
so devon got me this like sam porter
bridges uh death stranding
figurine super freaking cool
um he sent this to me for my birthday
earlier this year
and it is one of the best coolest gifts
i've got in a very long time
it's set up at my corridor corridor desk
but okay let's take a look at this and
make sure
[Music]
things are looking good all right so i
accidentally
piped that into the wrong section that's
why it didn't work
boom so we get a little bit of
differentiation here in the texture and
the way it's broken up
that feels super cool i dig that a lot
now we can also change the way again
this falloff map is crunched down
so we can see more of one texture
less of the other
if you break this up in the right way
you can also take the skew factor and
crunch that down to just get a different
look as well
and differentiate between
these two different vibes but i like
that a whole lot i think it looks really
good
we can take the color correction node
for both of these guys
and we can take the gamma maybe to like
0.5 and
maybe 0.75
or 0.9 basically you can color correct
it however you like
whatever fits your scene the best that
look to me looks too dark
but once we get our fog in here the
horizon fog
and it should should pop in
you know the fog is really going to wash
out the look of this thing
pretty quickly and it's not showing up
for some reason
but that is all good
there it is yeah so you see how the
horizon fog like
breaks up um and just fades out that
mountain but i still think it's a little
too dark
we can tweak that though based off of
this
reference so you can see that everything
kind of bleeds
up into this mountain and the sky is
very dark around it
everything kind of is brought together
by the atmosphere and the fog layers
so i'll go back into the mix material
i'll select both of those color
corrections and maybe we will just say
hey it's going to be 0.5
or 0.2
0.2 might be a bit much
but we can bring the brightness up
and start to get to something that's
like a little a little different here
but
what we're going to do next is we're
actually going to add
some jagged rocks around this mountain
in order to you know
again it's all based off the reference
you know we put this reference together
in the first episode
of this environmental master class and
we want to follow the reference that's
the whole point so you can see all these
different little jaggedy pieces of
mountain
all around um your main mountain
and you're gonna see the difference and
you're gonna see those those little like
foreground mountains pop out because
we're gonna have some fog and atmosphere
behind them as well
so what we want to do is kind of cherry
pick some of these models here and
bridge
and scatter them around our mountain in
a in a unique
way we're going to do it one by one to
make sure that it looks really nice and
it's perfect and it really fits
right so
let's see this is looking fine um i'm
wondering if we could do this
two different ways if we could
potentially
take this mountain right here control
drag to duplicate
scale it down
and then change the seed so we come back
up to landscape
and we take the seed to like 10.
oh i guess that's not the one which one
is this
here we go yeah you know you take the
seed to any different number
that's going to give you a different
look and automatically that that feels
better to me um i'm liking that look and
we need to push it behind
these mountains so let's let's do this
let's go to option and uncheck the check
camera option
okay that will allow us to hop out of
the camera and kind of move around our
scene a little bit
and as we move things that's updated in
the viewport okay
so i want to wrap this mountain
with different kind of
mountain mountainy features and i want
to angle them
in towards the mountain so maybe what
i'll do here
is we'll do this with a target
so i'll give the mountain a target tag
somewhere maybe under
rigging where would it be
hmm they changed all their tags so uh
shift c
will find you anything in the program so
you can say target and give it a target
tag
it's an animation tag all right cool and
then i'm going to make a null object
actually no i'll select this mountain
hold ctrl
and then make a null and that will spawn
the null right in the middle
of the the object you had selected okay
let's move that up into space just a
little bit and then
we'll say this target that we put on
this mountain right here
let me make that easier for you to see
it's going to be looking for a target
so the target will be this null boom
okay and now it's kind of it's pointed
that way
we want these mountains to be tilted
towards this main mountain
so you can see how using a target will
orient that in that way and when i
duplicate this
it's going to point towards that target
regardless so the more we make it
doesn't matter
it's all going to be pointed that way so
we can move this null up and down
to control the angle of each one of
those and you can come in here and also
no you can't tweak that but what this
will give us
is a quick way to get the look we're
going for
um and then we can come back later and
we can delete the targets and
and add little details and tweaks
afterwards
okay so let's keep working on it let's
change the seed of this because we don't
want any one
mountain to look the same so just change
that to 10
and consistently go back to our
reference to see
what's working and what's not working
okay
so this guy back here if you can see is
hovering just
over the mountain and it looks like
little rocky shelves
which i really like because you'll get
that nice under glow
underneath from the lava i definitely
want to replicate that
charles yeah man you're like yo shout
out to all those boys listen to ambient
music
watching these i'm listening to it right
now um i got it on
shuffle it's the best um
[Music]
it's such a vibe man yeah i got the
ambient music making these ambient
environments i love it it keeps me super
uh what's the word super creative man
it's the music that really gets me
creative
so let's just switch between these seeds
until we find something that we like
you know that's not bad we could maybe
rotate this
around no it's not going to let us
because of the target tag
let's keep adding a few more okay let's
just add a few more
and one of the
one of the the contest requirements was
to not touch the mountain
or change the silhouette of the mountain
too much so i'm being very aware of that
i don't want to start adding more
mountains like
all up around this i want this to be the
focus the central point
of of the scene so i'm keeping that in
mind while adding these mountain
figures around the main mountain all
right
oh that's good see that has a nice
little rocky
piece on it and i can always come back
into this
camera here
and we can adjust the the height
of these guys
to get us that like that shelf that rock
shelf look
that'll be around like the back side of
this thing
now i don't like how like how circular
this one is
so i'm gonna just keep changing the seed
until i find something i like
very nice i'm just trying to give it
like some depth here
and make sure that there's an actual
like differentiation between
the space um between this foreground
mountain and this background mountain
so we can add some fog and stuff in
between
so i'm going to keep duplicating and
changing the seed
that's pretty cool i like that
very cool
and we'll keep going
changing the seed to find something that
looks right
maybe one more off to the side here
like a lot of small ones is a good idea
but okay let's go ahead and if we delete
these targets are they going to change
nope perfect
so let's hop out of the camera
and see what we can see here so that was
that's looking pretty sweet
um
[Music]
we can rotate these around
to get different looks as well
and we're just adding like depth in
layers
to to this mountain
that's perfect that like shelf rocky
shelf
is amazing
sweet so i'm a fan of that i like how
that looks
um now i don't know if we need to change
out the texture
um let's go to a hundred percent let's
just call this
one and we'll see what we can see
welcome everybody if you guys are just
joining we are taking
a stock mountain in cinema 4d and we're
turning it into something like this here
volcano with bunch of different foggy
layers in the foreground that
lead up to this giant lava flow peak
with everything coming down the side so
i think we're at a point now where we
can start
adding the lava flow elements down the
side of this mountain
and giving it a really cool look and
we'll break up the look here
with uh with some noise so we have some
hot red
glow with some warm white glow and and
uh
and really split that up we'll get some
glow on the backside of the mountain
there's a little under
cast here under light on the back of
these guys and then we'll wrap it up
with
this the steam vents and actually an
animated steam vent
that will use like action vfx elements
as a png with alpha to get that look and
i'll walk you guys through that whole
thing so
very excited very very excited
you guys also have to realize too like
if you're working on something and it
looks like butt
like right now this mountain looks like
butt because there's no atmosphere
you have to realize that there's it's
gonna get better all right guys like
it's gonna get better from here
and i'm not just saying this to say like
oh hang in and keep watching until the
end no
like i'm saying this for you guys
because there are times where i get
discouraged when creating something and
it
because it doesn't look the way i want
it to feel or want it to look
when creating it and i'll get i'll get
impatient with myself
and i'll get bummed out and it'll cause
me i've quit
certain um you know certain renders or
certain piece
certain drawings i've given up on them
because i'm like you know
it's not looking how i want it to look
right now and it should be
so i'm giving up no just stick in okay
take the time
and make it look really cool i promised
you're going to be surprised with
yourself when you
actually stick in and continue working
on something
you're going to get a really really cool
result at the end so
don't worry about it you know don't
don't stress too much about it
also i just got an idea i think that the
the mountains are super dark in the
background i think we can actually
darken up this mid-ground layer
this little sandy area so we can we can
darken that up
and that's going to help us kind of
blend into the mountain in the
background
but i'm not going to worry about that
right now again because we're here
to make make this mountain look legit so
i'm wondering if i can
come into my mountain material
and we take our transform
nodes for our uh for a mountain and we
we we scale them down so we take it
down to 50 instead of a hundred
i think that looks a little bit better
i think that certainly looks a little
bit better the coal mine wall
let's see where are you at yeah this guy
right here
maybe we take that one what if we take
that one to 200 what does that look like
interesting what if we take it to one
so it looks like the coal mine wall is
like our main
kind of our main texture here i'm
wondering if we can reveal a bit more of
the other texture
yeah like this you know so that's
revealing more of our main texture
or the other texture rather and we can
take
that guy and we can scale that down
maybe to 30.
okay so now you start to see um
[Music]
tiling which we definitely don't want so
let's take it back to 50
and let's take the coal mine wall back
to 50.
re-render our scene
and you get a crash that's how it
happens um so you guys got to make sure
you're saving your stuff
invert
dude you about you're riding on thin ice
right now son
you say who am i what am i doing well my
name is clinton jones welcome to the
stream
i'm a director and vfx artist and i like
to take every saturday
to basically teach you guys a little bit
of what i know
when it comes to visual effects so
um for those of you who don't know i
work at corridor digital
and you know we got a show called vfx
arts react where we
you know we break down visual effects
all the time every single saturday
basically
um let's go ahead and open this
up real quick
i think this is the most recent one
yep
awesome and i'll just save this as a new
version
but yeah we didn't lose anything we got
all of our mountain stuff in place
but yeah the whole reason that you all
are here um
is is to learn right we're all here to
learn
and grow together in the passions and
the
the
hobbies that we really enjoy but don't
do enough of
on the weekend or during the week so
we're taking this time together to do it
together um
so invert i hope you're you're here and
you're ready to learn and you want to
learn some vfx
if not you know hang out just have a
good time
and if you're not trying to have a good
time then
boy boy
just make it pleasant for the others
that's all i ask
all right y'all so let's keep this up
okay
let's go and render the scene and let's
just try and get that scale down and
then we'll go in we'll start adding this
lava flow which i'm super amped for
that's what i'm
most excited for
all right
welcome to everybody just popping into
um i hope you guys are having a good
saturday i hope you guys had a good week
um you know i've been working super hard
super hard um i mean this whole year has
been a tough one
been basically working two jobs at once
you know the corridor job and then
um my channel here so it's been
it's been intense it's been a really
tough one and i really gotta make sure
to take
the time to take breaks that's my
biggest thing i've been
biting off a whole lot
all right
so let's let's work on the scale here
so we said we wanted this guy both of
these guys
at 50. we brought those down to 50 and
then we actually
cranked the gradient to reveal a bit
more
of this other texture here
maybe we take the coal mine wall and we
go back to 100 because that was actually
that wasn't looking too bad
sweet okay that's that's not half
bad at all coal mine wall let's go to
300 let's see
what the heck we're seeing
one so it doesn't look like we're
getting that big of a difference here
but we've set this up in a way for it to
be easily accessible and easily
tweakable here
with this falloff map so we can change
it to the irae version and get a
different look
and hopefully it doesn't crash on us
save save save
but okay we can always come back to that
let's work on the lava flow
okay this is this is gonna be the
biggest look
to creating this volcano so i'm gonna
select them
our main mountain okay and
let's do let's do uh
i'm gonna duplicate it i'll rename this
to
main mountain back and that's for backup
and then we have main mountain and i'm
gonna turn off the backup
holding alt i'll click this once turns
these little
these lights green press them again
and it turns them red the top one the
light is for the viewport
the bottom one is for the render so if
we were to take this main mountain
and we turn off the top light you're not
going to see it in the viewport but you
will see it in the renderer
if i turn it off in the renderer
obviously you don't see it there but if
i turn it back
on in the viewport you see it here so
you know it's handy i use these things
all the time
so let's we've created our backup right
let's hop out of the camera and get up
in
here and see what we can see okay
to create this lava flow what i'm
thinking about doing
is is basically this if we go to
wireframe mode and we take a look at
this thing
we want to select these polygons and
basically give the polygons that we
select
a material and a miss of material that
you know emits light
but i think these are a little too
chunky this is a little too broken up
to get us a nice clean line like we see
here
in our actual reference now there's
different ways to do this
i could certainly create like some sort
of drip
looking um effect in
photoshop and that might not be the
worst way
to do it um i think the thing that's
keeping me
from from doing that is
is basically a realistic looking um
brush right because if i go in here
and i look at this i guess it is all
kind of just branching off
and spilling off
and i guess that's what i'd be doing if
i were to be selecting
polygons so maybe we'd do this in
photoshop
instead of
hmm
the only reason i'm not doing it in
photoshop is because i want to actually
have the lava flow around the mountain
here in a realistic way
but there's not that many
little mountains that break this up so
you see it runs down the mountain
and then it'll split off like this now
what you could do is probably do some
sort of like
simulation using like x particles or
something and have a bunch of particles
and draw
you can draw a line down this or draw
some sort of spline down this
that could work as well and the cool
thing about 3d is the fact that you can
do
one thing like 10 different ways
i'm not going to do all 10 different
ways i'm going to choose one way and go
with it
um and yeah i'm using i'm using bridge
materials
for the mountain super great program
boom looking super
nice i just chose two different ones and
then you know blended between the two
i might come back later and choose
different ones to
to mix it up with um
but what do you guys think i'm gonna
leave it to you guys should i
make this mountain editable and select
polygons and then
apply material material to that polygon
or should i go in photoshop and create
like some sort of
uh you know
uh like lava mat and
drop that on top of this mountain how do
you how do you guys think i should do
this i'm gonna leave it up to you
um invert what's the difference between
cinema 4d and maya
um basically maya is more of a
studio program in in in the sense that
okay both of them
cinema 40 and maya they both
um are 3d programs you can create 3d
work inside these programs
and um you know you could do an animated
short film with cinema 4d
you could do an animated short film with
maya but the difference is that maya is
more set up for
studios in the sense that you have um
like a modeling department followed by a
texturing department
you pass that off to the lighting
department and then you pass that off to
the rendering department
um so it's kind of like set up for a
pipeline in a studio
cinema 4d however very similar to like
blender
these programs are more for like the
individual you can certainly use them in
a studio
but it's not built for a studio this is
built for individual artists
and they just they do everything really
well
and it's not split up like it would be
split up for a studio
that's kind of the that's like the main
difference at least in my
my personal um personal
experience i have used maya um for about
three months but cinema 4d has been my
long-standing
go-to 3d program i love it a lot and a
lot of people here enjoy blender as well
alright so let's check what do you guys
want to do
um
yeah you're saying okay just make it
editable and have a back
back up uh sculpt sculpt it okay it
could be interesting
assign polygons so i can edit down the
road yeah
sim would sim would be more time
consuming that's definitely true
yeah invert my any 3d program is very
complicated very confusing
and you really
will have the best experience and the
best time in any 3d program
if you find a reason to learn it so if
you don't have a reason to learn a 3d
program
it's going to be boring and it's going
to seem monotonous and whatnot
but if you can find ways to to use the
program and come up with reasons as to
why you would use the program that's
really when your mind starts going crazy
and you can come up with cool ways cool
interesting ways
and it's just like with anything like if
you're not into golf you're not going to
care about a golf
anything you're not going to probably
anything about golf but if you have a
reason to get into golf you're gonna
start researching it and look
looking into it
so i don't have a golf hole
to fill in my life i don't need to go
out and golf
but if i did i'd find a way to learn a
little bit more about golf
you know okay so guys it looks like
we're gonna do uh we're just gonna
select these polygons i think that's
gonna be the fastest way
and it'll be the the easiest way i think
see you norlin thanks for joining man um
okay so
we backed up our mountain let's go ahead
and subdivide it that means we're going
to add
more polygons to this in order to get
cleaner lines so as you can see
um we can add to the depth
and the width so let's try 600 on the
depth
maybe 800 so these numbers need to be
about double
so 400 one to two right in order to
appear as squares so maybe we just
double that from there so we go
400 by um all right sorry 800 by 1600
and i think from a distance we're going
to be okay that's going to give us the
best
look all right um this guy
these guys back here we can probably
take these down to 200 by 200.
so that they're not as dense you know
because again it's all about saving
computer juice you got to save your
computer juice
all right invert thanks for stopping by
man thanks for asking some good
questions
okay so guys let's go ahead and make
this mountain editable boom
i hit c and it's editable now um
i'm gonna go ahead and pause the viewer
here because we don't need to see it
and we can come in here and we can start
we can come in here and start
selecting if i set my radius to 1 i can
start selecting
like lava drips just like that yeah
so let's do it from how we can do this
what do you think go back to the camera
like this and
come in here and start adding little
lava flow
areas um i definitely want to reference
that concept art we put together so i'm
going to open up pure ref
and i'm going to go ahead and drop in an
image
oh um let's see one moment guys let me
just
open this up
cool so now i have this in here and i
can zoom in
um let's try
getting this down to like this and then
we can really see this
while we work so it starts up at the top
and it kind of speckles off and breaks
off as it gets down towards the bottom
so that's what we're going to
to replicate let's hop out of the camera
let's come into this kind of view here
and i'm going to get rid of
or hide rather all these other mountains
that we created
to just give me the best view of this
one mountain right here
sweet okay
so i set my selection tool
to a radius of one
i wonder if i can go point one no it's
only one
mode will be normal
sweet all right cool
all right so let's give this a shot i'm
just gonna i'm holding
shift in order to um
select multiple bits so i can do this
bit here and if i go over here
it's not going to work because i'm not
holding shift but if i hold shift
then i get both right
so let's come through here and let's
just go to town i'm just going to do
like little
little bits and there's a way to hide
this gizmo i think it's like alt
s it's definitely not alt s
um let me google it
if you guys can find the answer before
before i can find out in this tutorial
you guys get bonus points
it's okay okay all right so i got the
answer
does anybody know i don't see it it's
alt
d all right alt d is what we need not
alt s
so we'll go back and we'll go again all
right so alt d
will hide your gizmo that way you can
kind of keep it out the way
so let's try it again yeah
so i'm just coming through here and i'm
like
just getting a little bit of lava flow
and it always starts from the top and
comes down
and it breaks off and goes on these
different paths
and it looks like it kind of breaks off
and like speckles off down here off to
the side
we have these different like
broken up layers of lava there's some
that come
down and runs down here i'm kind of
going going along the shape of our
mountain
something like that off to the side and
they're all connected that's the things
they're all connected
so this goes over the edge this goes
over the edge there
and it's all kind of seeping and flowing
down
our mountain and joining up into these
main channels these main streams
so this all flows downwards boom
right kind of flowing down here hitting
these
these little crevices and flowing off to
the side like this
and holding shift to really get all
these points down here and i want it
i want to actually have a lava pool down
here and we'll do that later
we'll certainly make that look nice a
little bit later
but this is just for all the main flow
and we can always come back and add more
to this too you know if we don't like
the look we have we can we can come back
and and do more with this
and alpha matte yes i absolutely will
add an emissive texture to this
this polygon selection here
let's see what this looks like i'm
excited so
i'm going to go to select and i'm going
to
hit set selection all right so that's
going to give us a selection for a
mountain
and let's go ahead and make a octane
diffuse material i'm an octane
you can do do this and whatever you guys
are probably in blender doing this too
that's okay but we'll make it a miss of
texture so i'll make a blackbody
emission
we'll come in here and we want to give
it a
a color alright so let's first actually
let's
apply this to our material
so i'm going to let's see under the main
mountain
we have this selection tag this triangle
i'm going to apply the emission texture
to our main mountain
and then i'm going to right here in this
little selection box
drag that triangle and now
just those polygons we had selected if i
double click it
that'll just be the emissive texture
alright
so let's go back to camera view i'm
super amped to see how this looks
and let's render it and see what happens
interesting so my the first thing i see
is it doesn't appear to be that
shiny and
it looks very pixelated
so the pixelated look
now i wonder if i can do this with
there's another there might be another
way to do this in cinema
that allows us to easily and quickly
you know adjust but let's keep going
down this path and see if we need to
change
okay so we'll add our mountains back in
that we added
and let's set this to 0.5
and let's first make sure that this is
actually glowing
okay so
surface brightness we'll check that okay
so now it's actually glowing
let's set the temperature down to like a
thousand
even 500 which that looks insane um
let's
let's try 750.
thousand
and maybe what we need to do maybe it's
too bright so we set that to 50.
yeah a vertex map
i think a vertex map is what i'm looking
for
yeah definitely i think i think using
the vertex painter or vertex map is
going to help me
um help me make that look smoother but
right now let's go ahead and lock in the
light let's lock in this look here of
our emissive and then we'll come back
and we'll
we'll tweak the uh the actual lava flow
okay so one thing at a time
let me save a new scene
so i'm just gonna have this off to the
side here um
and i'll bring it in as i need to as i
reference it
so a texture let's go ahead and drop in
an rgb
spectrum texture
and already something happened
it's actually giving the mountain itself
some glow which is really cool and kind
of what
we want kind of what we're going for um
i'm going to actually add
some mountains around the back of this
thing
alt d to bring our gizmo back in and i
just want to bring
these mountains around the back side
so that we can get some nice glow on the
back of our mountain which we'll
probably use with like some lights or
something
let's change the seed
yeah just like that cool so
in octane you can set the camera
in under the camera imager to
saturate to white if i set that to zero
that'll basically look like that it look
kind of ugly but if i set it to 0.2
anything that's
super saturated and super bright will be
saturate or will be kind of set to
a white instead of the actual color it
just kind of matches real life a little
bit more
um the flow of the lava like the
the thickness of these streaks is making
the mountain look smaller
that's true i'm gonna go back and we're
gonna adjust that but right now what i'm
trying to lock in is the lighting okay
so let's see
i should be able to just choose the
color unless this needs to go
if i take this to like a blue
interesting okay so let's let's try
like a red orange
color
ah yeah and that's not that's really not
the look we're going for it's
really intense so maybe it's the surface
brightness that's
blowing that out
but at the end of the day like this does
have to be bright
[Music]
um
i wonder is is it supposed to be
distribution instead
and we definitely want to break this up
with some noise
projection will be
uvw to xyz to uvw
for noise and we'll give it a transform
as well
and we're going to break that up let's
see
i'm wondering if that will go into
distribution and then we take the noise
give it
yep okay so that looks
half correct
and then maybe the noise has a a
gradient ramp on it
and that's going to determine our color
which that looks like it works but
it's looking like
hmm
you know i wonder
if we go with the photoshop route
i'm wondering if that will be better
certainly we can do the vertex painting
route
but if we go into photoshop i'm just
going to open photoshop real quick
i'm wondering if we can do something
pretty quick
so let's transform this down
something like that we also want to we
probably want to mix this with
a a gradient or i'm sorry
my mind my mind is going to fall off yes
we want to mix that with a fall off
and we'll say it is a 90 degree or it
should be 180 degrees
very nice
so the best way to test if this fall off
is working is to just make a sphere
bring it up
drop a new material on here put the fall
off into the diffuse
channel that's by default working
uh normal versus ira and then we have 90
degree which
is it looks like that's what we want and
then 180 degree
let's take that 180 and let's give it a
gradient
and we'll crunch it
but i'm pretty sure the the 90 degree
is what we're going for
and we can flip it we can say negative
one
so it's inverted
so that'll always inform me if i just
need to test something and figure out if
it's working
i'll bring it down to the most basic
mode
so go back to the fall off 90 degree
and this can be six i think we can solo
this too
hmm
i gotta find that find that sweet spot
and in the octane camera you can
actually give it some glow as well
i think that'll definitely help post
processing uh we'll enable that
and we definitely want all those lens
flares so we'll take the glare amount to
one
um we'll set the angle to
[Music]
negative 90 and i'm just going to take
the glare blur all the way up
and in fact i'll just take that that
angle to zero
so it's looking like a minecraft
mountain right now just because of the
quality
of those brush strokes so we can do
let's see if we were to do vertex
painting
trying to figure out
the best way to do that um i certainly
do know though that if we come into
photoshop
and we make say like uh
a 4k map here so 3840
by 3840
or no technically it's 38 is it 3860
no 3840.
all right we got crying babies in the
background it's time to shut the door
all right
so i'm wondering if we can like piece
together
water texture
or like water drip texture there's not a
lot of water textures
online
but we might just have to do this from
hand so or by hand
so i'm going to come in here and
let's
switch this up
so we get something like this but that
is too thick
this really needs to be built up
in a very very small tiny way so
my size here will be 5 pixels
and let's just paint out
one half of this mountain and we'll go
down
we'll go just go down the line
and see what we can do
we'll see if this looks any good
now there's an easier way to do this i
am all ears
so i'll have some streams break off and
then rejoin
like this one here
and like there's definitely a lot more
streams up towards the top
and it's kind of like a river system
that's really what this is
is a river system
so we'll get more and more detailed with
this
and it's really just experimenting i'm
here to experiment
and you can set your brush size even
smaller
for these kind of little bits down here
and you know it's kind of like lightning
actually maybe lightning is the best
um kind of reference for this
and i might be able to take a bunch of
different lightning images
and use those to
build out a map a lava map
you know
but it's very very interesting how this
looks both like a river
and lightning which is pretty crazy how
nature works you know
and i'll come in with a black brush and
erase some of this
this is going to help break it up a
little bit
give it a little bit more
texture
vfx wizard that's a good idea using a
height map of the mountain to
get a nice reference i do think though
that
this could potentially give me something
that that would work just because
my mountain doesn't have too many
features on it i'm kind of faking these
like little
turns and angles and stuff i'm gonna go
ahead and save this out and see
what we're looking at and i'm going to
make sure if i hit ctrl
r i'm going to set this up so that it's
in the center point
right here so we'll take this guy
and we'll just get that right in the
center point right here
and we could easily just you know
duplicate duplicate this with ctrl
j spin it around so that we have some on
the back side as well
and maybe what i can do is take both of
these
well maybe okay here control um we'll do
control g
to group everything to make sure that
lock is turned off
i'm gonna duplicate that control e to
make it editable
and then i'm gonna see what happens if i
content aware fill these areas
i'm going to hit shift backspace
oh interesting it gives us a little
something but it doesn't really do much
it's fine let's take this let's save
this as just like a png
and see what happens
all right so that's the before that
looks so bad um
so i want to do a mixed material once
again
all right
so let's go into the node editor
and we we want to basically
break up
the rock texture and the emissive
texture
with that map we just made so let's go
mix material we'll create one
we'll pipe this rock mix material into
mix material one
and then for material two i'm just going
to drag in this
emissive texture holding shift will get
the entire hierarchy for you
you can right click and auto arrange it
and that it goes into material 2 and out
of the amount
we have an image texture
and that's going to be
that map we just made the lava map
so let's apply let's actually invert
this
so we'll switch
we'll switch these around
and we'll set this to float because it's
a black and white image
and now what we'll do is just apply that
new mix material to the mountain and see
what we get
reload our scene
and take a look at the difference
so our mapping is off we need to change
the projection
the projection is going to be box
and we need to transform it as well
we'll transform it up to 100
and what we also need is
it cannot loop so we just need to select
the image texture and instead of wrap
around
we'll do black color so that way it's
only being
it's only being added once to our model
and i'm just going to use
the transform tools to try and get it to
sit directly
on top of this mountain
hmm
so it's proving difficult to get this
right on top of the mountain
um so it's it's doing something but it's
it's difficult to control
certainly it difficult to control it
this way
hey um
yeah i'm wondering if the vertex paint
is the option
here um so we're kind of just going
through
going through the options to figure out
the best way to do this
it doesn't look half bad but i'm also
seeing
areas these white areas where um we
don't really
we don't want any white areas so really
what it's going to be here
is if we get rid of the noise we kind of
need to get rid of the noise
so that it's all just lava back here
yeah world creator terrain stuff i think
would be useful
but i don't have world creator
i don't
yeah it does need bloom so you can come
into the camera imager
and work on that to get that look
going
and it's too red i feel like it needs to
be a mixture between red and yellow
so maybe what we could do with this
gradient instead of black obviously it's
going to be
kind of an orangish yellowy color
that is starting to look
close closer at least
the bloom is just way too intense
so maybe it starts out as red
now it starts out as like a white yellow
and then cools off to like this red
reddish color
but that's not that's not the worst
but i do think honestly coming coming
into like uh
google and doing something like uh
lightening texture
and we use this
as a way to build up
and create our lava flow so we would
take something like this
um so we do like texture lightening
on black maybe
i mean we could also do this in after
effects too
because after effects does have a
lightning plug-in but you know what i'm
saying you see how this like branches
off there's like these main streaks and
then they branch off and get weaker and
weaker
it's exactly what we're going for this
kind of a look here
lava flow coming all down throughout all
this
that i could see that really working
it also looks very similar to a tree
it's really crazy how nature
uh has all these different patterns and
similarities
but remember how i said like you'll
create something and it just won't look
that good
um and you need to keep working on it
well that's exactly what i need to keep
doing here if i want this to look
halfway decent i need to keep coming in
here and keep like
making this more detailed
because this isn't half bad i do think
one of you guys gave the idea of coming
in here like this
we'll do we'll make a new camera
and we will hover
right above our image
negative 90
and we'll just be right above our
mountain
we can change our aspect ratio to 1000
by
1000 we get right above here
and we want z depth that's what we're
we're looking for so we'll go into our
render settings octane render settings
we'll go down to octane renderer and
under render passes
info we'll do the z depth slider
we'll work that and we'll try and get a
look here
that actually shows our mountain and
it's not really
it's not really shown as much here
let me get in closer maybe and it's just
it's not giving us that much height
detail
let's try again
you know i want more detail in that and
it's not giving me what we need so maybe
we take this okay
we unlock it
and we save out a png
this will be our lava map reference
we'll come into
photoshop we'll open up that reference
and didn't export the z depth pass
for whatever reason
so let me just grab this pop into
photoshop
paste it and we'll crunch these levels
down
let's see if we can't get a look out of
this
so white will be the bot let's actually
invert it
around that doesn't invert okay
we'll invert it here
and then we'll throw some levels on it
that kind of gives us something
something to go with
ctrl shift i
will invert your selection
no i do not want yet
you can go up to select and let's see
you know image
trim and that'll just trim out all the
transparent pixels
and we could use this you know it's
super super tiny but
i think we can make something like this
work in order for us
to just have some sort of reference as
to where this lava is going
if we want to continue down this path
here because
it's actually a more improved version of
what we did originally
so i do think it is better
so i'm going to keep working on this
here
that's not bad at all
you know and then you get some like
some lights back here that can really
like punch up
the look of this lava so we have a light
we can bring it back in here
and we'll use this light to
kind of shine and illuminate these
these little crevices here so let's get
in close
and we'll take the visibility and and
just turn off camera visible
right so we're only seeing the the glow
from that light
and what you want to do is actually if
we bring it down
into these little crevices
we can just kind of scatter them all
around
down here to give us a nice look in this
mountain
and we'll certainly set that to
um let's go into the light and we'll say
the texture is going to be an
rgb spectrum and we want that to be kind
of like a
a reddish orange texture
or color rather
something like that because based on our
reference
we can see that glow underneath
right all back here um usually it's
mostly it's mostly here i'm seeing it
that kind of under glow look
so i'm going to just scatter these
behind the mountain and kind of shine
them up onto these little crevices
you
um
what happened not enough memory
interesting
so i'm going to save this we'll see if
it has a new iteration
call it j and let's give it a little
fresh
reboot here and see what we can get
zach yes certainly i could make him
sphere lights are bi-directional
i might certainly might do that but
we'll see what it looks like at first
then we'll go back in
yeah so there's a bunch of different
ways to go about this process
and it's tough you know because i feel
like i don't want to waste your guys
time so i don't want to keep like
doing it one way and then stopping and
going back doing it another way
but certainly that's kind of part of
part of the process it's part of
i think some of you might say it's part
of the drawl as
uh you know to these streams
but it's tough you know i'm finding a
balance between experimenting and
and you know just digging into different
ways of doing things and also keeping it
entertaining at the same time so
it'd be nice if uh you know
it'd certainly be nice if i can get it
right the first time every single time
it'd be the most
the fastest quickest way but
it can't always be that way and it
usually never
is especially when it's your first time
doing something
if this was a tutorial that i was
recording um
you know i'd i'd have to basically
do it two or three times before i
actually did it
but since it's a live stream i just
don't have the time especially since i
have a full-time job at corridor
it's a lot of work certainly a lot of
work
all right let's render and see what we
got
so we're getting that glow here on the
mountain which is exactly what we're
going for
that's a really nice look
this guy can probably be turned around
don't know if this one's doing anything
for us back here
yeah we can delete that and this one
here actually too i don't think it's
doing much for us either
it's really this one that's lighting up
this little piece
that i like a lot and
i also might just grab this
light and
we'll go ahead and hold ctrl and we're
going to
pop this into the center of the mountain
here
and i want to make it seem like there is
a
pool of lava underneath so i'm gonna
under light this whole mountain
from this little crevice okay
so that's certainly an interesting look
um i might take that down to like
a hundred i don't want it to be too
crazy i want to keep it kind of subtle
and there's some nice lava flow at the
base as well
so you know i might have something like
running through here a light that runs
through the center of this so i'm gonna
continue duplicating these and just kind
of
basically do a small little stream
throughout the center of this
and i'll drop these as low as i can
bring them
and i'll see what kind of lighting that
gives me
and i'll shine these back onto
the rocks themselves
yeah you could put a volume around the
entire volcano certainly
um and that's kind of what i'm going to
do here
basically i want to have uh
different layers of fog in order to
really
keep these mountains poking out and
standing out
now one thing i really want to do here
is add that atmosphere and add that fog
in an interesting way
so i think you can certainly have
some stuff like this i think if we add
this fog layer
i feel like this fog should appear i
don't know why it's not appearing right
now
there it is if we duplicate that fog
layer
so i'll ctrl drag it so it's duplicated
and we move it
back towards the mountain
and we give the mountain just a bit of
fog
an atmosphere
so if we turn that on and off
it's very subtle let's see if we can't
really work this into place
oh it's so thin it's very thin so we
want to open this up a little bit more
and now this is when your computer
starts to chug
and if you set the voxel size to a
larger number
that'll really help you know the
viewport settings and
it'll it'll help save some more computer
juice for you
let's see what that looks like
all right so the fog definitely too
thick
but we want the light to shine through
so i'll boost up the scattering phase
and i'll set the density to instead of
0.01.001
that's too much 0.005
and it looks really cool because it
starts to like
diffuse the light back here and give it
a really
interesting look now
the little sand bar that is in front
of the mountain needs
to be darker it's a little too much so
i'm going to find that and let's
actually hide the horizon fog
from our viewport so we can see a little
bit better
and i'm going to select that little bit
that landscape too and it looks like
it's this
going after this mix material so i want
to darken that up
so with the mixed material selected
go ahead and find out what that mixed
material is made from
so i think let's see if i can
come here it's tire soil entire mud
so tire soil entire mud that's what the
mix material is made from
right there okay so i'm gonna duplicate
both of these
all three really so tire soil tire mud
we duplicated those and i'm going to
call these
dark be the dark version
because i'm going to basically darken
these up in order to get the mid ground
to match the background a little bit
more
now the octane mix material i'll call
this
dark mud as well
and i want to reference
the new materials that i just made
okay so let's apply that new mix
material
to that layer and it looks like nothing
changed which is perfect that's exactly
what we want let's go ahead and save
we'll hop into the node editor and let's
go ahead and change
both of these mud materials i'm going to
go ahead and auto arrange and make sure
i'm
holding shift i'm able to move the
entire
hierarchy we'll auto arrange that
and this okay so it's the diffuse that i
want to adjust
so i'm going to drop a color correction
node in between there
let's just take the let's try taking the
gamma up to two
on both of these and see what happens
let's get rid of the fog for a second
let's try darkening this up even more
um i want to give myself
a let's see
let's render the region
right in there cool
save and re-render the scene
so changing the brightness to zero
doesn't do too much actually
so maybe what i need to do instead of
adjusting that
maybe i just need to adjust
the specular
because it might be just reflecting a
ton
a ton of light here
hmm
i'm gonna hop out of the camera
and see maybe
why this is not darkening up
all right so it's working it's actually
darkening
so i guess it's the
the roughness let me try the roughness
and adjusting that
or in fact if it if it is the the
specular
all right so that's not reflective at
all now
so i'll go back into camera
and see what that looks like
all right so that looks horrible that
definitely looks horrible
having some reflection is obviously what
we want so
um let's try changing that to a mid gray
for both of these
and maybe we need to take the contrast
of that to zero
that's starting to feel a little bit
better and we'll take the transform of
the noise that's breaking it up to maybe
35
so it's just a little bit larger
okay cool
so we'll just make it a little bit more
reflective because we don't want it to
match the mountain color we want it to
be just a little
brighter than the mountain color so
that's not it's actually not that
bad um
cool take that background fog
drop it on see what we get
liam okay so uh i used
this image here that i created in
photoshop to really get the lava looking
nice
and i just did this with a brush and i
adjusted
basically the way it was sitting on top
of the mountain just with
rotational bits and transformer rotation
and i made sure that my camera the post
processing on my camera
was glowing the
that mountain mountainous lava back
there so i want to set maybe that
even more 200 and 100 to get that nice
lava glow
that looks super nice i added some
lights back here too and
a little bit of fog just to
you know really kind of bring that bring
that back in now i'm still
not getting
i'm still not getting this mountain
exactly the way i want so i think what
i'm going to do actually here
is i'm going to open up after effects
and we're going to do a cool little
trick
so i'm going to add some like steam
vents
and stuff actually animated steam vents
and i'm gonna do this by using um
different stock footage
with uh with alpha baked in so i'm gonna
save it as a png
sequence and i'm gonna place little
cards
around the mountain areas and around and
behind the rocks
so it looks like it's actually steaming
so i've never done this before and i'm
very excited to do so
so what we're gonna do
what is going on
come on after effects i literally just
opened you and you're gonna crash on me
like this
maybe i'll have to open a stable version
of after effects and not
after effects beta my goodness
i'm just maybe maybe i'll give it one
more shot if it does it again
then we've we've done what we can
so yeah i mean like this is really what
we're going for we're going to add some
trees and roots and rocks later
but i'm really trying to get the overall
general feeling
of the render down first before i start
getting into the micro stuff
i'm not too worried about um the
foreground bits
like the you know the tree stumps that's
all stuff we can add
once we make our landscape look really
nice definitely get some fallen trees in
here that we can
we can bring from mega scans and maybe a
little bit of uh
of uh what do i use forester right is a
program that i use
for trees and whatnot okay come on after
effects
i think we're good okay so i'm gonna
import
um the small scale smoke plumes
from action vfx action vfx
if you guys are unfamiliar is basically
a website where you can download
a ton of amazing stock footage
and this isn't sponsored by them though
it would be cool if it was
because i use their stuff all the time
but yeah so small scale
smoke plume is what i'm looking for
small scale
smoke plumes these guys boom uh
perfect let's import those and see
what we got i also want to let's put
those in a folder
smoke plumes
and then i'm also going to import the um
fog and atmosphere pack they have as
well
so i just double click down here in the
viewport or in the uh
project browser area atmosphere
smoke and fog volume 2.
so all this good stuff
we'll import that
so looking at the reference okay you can
see
there's a bunch of smoke kind of rising
up and around the mountain
a lot of like it looks like it's in a
cloud almost
so i want to place a bunch of cards um a
bunch of planes
where these animated smoke layers can
sit
in between okay
so back in after effects let's just take
a look at what we're looking at
so these are some small scale stuff this
is probably too small for what we're
doing
i want to find like
maybe five or six really good ones i'm
going to export those
and then we'll use those and put them on
cards
so i'm just going to go through and find
the best ones here
i don't want anything too small
like that might not be bad
i also don't want anything too heavy
or too opaque
and i want to fill a large area so the
ones that are like
standing up pretty tall may not be the
best for what we're trying to do
so i'm just looking in this window here
oh here's a good one
yeah that's great certainly want that
so it looks like it's this windy smoke
that's gonna do
a good job for us
yup that's a good one
that's a solid one
and since we have 88 frames we can move
these around and shift these around
to like different um
different points of time in order in
order to get a different look
all right so let's check out the fog
layers let's see what we got here
so this is some like low-lying fog i
don't think that's going to be good for
us
so let me just go through and see what
we got
there's something like this maybe
i don't know if that's going to be
what we're going for maybe this one here
is very subtle it's almost like a cloud
but i think that could be cool so i'm
going to pop that in
that's not bad we can use that too um
really what i'm looking for is to make
sure that the smoke stays within the
frame so i'm going to go through these
and mask out
the borders so they're black right
that's too much
i think that's good though i think
that's a nice look
for us so we have these six here that
we'll use
so let's go through these and basically
if you just hold down
the uh this mark this box tool you can
do the ellipse tool and double click it
and it'll give you
a perfect ellipse around your image i'm
gonna go ahead and feather that
and then expand it so just choke the
mask
in so now we're only getting like just
this little bit here
you're not seeing any edges which is
exactly what we want okay
so i can take that mask and i'm just
going to duplicate it across
everything
weird it didn't copy it how we wanted to
yep there we go
no borders perfect exactly what we want
awesome awesome do the same for this guy
and for this last one
cool so now what we want to do is well
first
we'll save our project file obviously we
don't want to lose this
transparent smoke awesome okay so what
you want to do
um you want to get rid of this black
okay so the best way to do that is with
unmolt
which is a tool that you can get from
what is it red giant it's a great red
giant tool if you don't have it you
could also use the built-in after
effects one it's called like a
remove color matting
is that the one
no i think it's still called unmult in
after effects it's like uh
or uh transparent background alpha what
is it alpha
[Music]
i know there's a free version of unmolt
around
i'm forgetting the name of the built-in
after effects one
but you're basically just getting rid of
the black around your image so unmult
does a fantastic job of that you can
still see that you have
um you know your element but when you
turn on alpha
it's it's actually looking really nice
so you could do
let's see let's put in just like a gray
background
50 gray or even better yet let's just
load in
our concept art
and that way we can check the alpha
levels over our concept art
see what it looks like
so this is our fog layer sitting nicely
i think i think that's great
and we'll we'll want to apply the unmult
effect
to all of our different smoke layers
perfect
perfect so i'm going to go through and
basically just
export out
[Music]
these six different versions i'm going
to extend my duration project duration
we'll go
2000 frames which should be plenty
and we'll just one by one do these png
sequences
and if you don't have a png
sequence um
setting already set up let's do that so
basically
we can make a template all right in the
setting i always like to do underscore
at the beginning because then it's
always at the top
png sequence
and we'll edit and we will just make it
a png sequence great fantastic
um you're gonna want it with alpha so
it's rgb plus alpha very very important
it's rgb
plus alpha millions of colors plus
that's fine i think that's
uh either 8 or 16 bit
trillions of colors is either 16 or 32
bit i forget
but you it's very important it's rgb
plus alpha you want the alpha
okay so that's a png sequence
with alpha we'll hit okay
and let's find a spot for this render
okay
so vfx this will be
render output is exactly what we want
so this is
windy smoke
and we'll let that go
so wow it looks like that's gonna take a
minute let's um let's focus on some
other stuff while that goes yeah
but first how is everybody doing are you
guys hanging in there give me some
thumbs ups if you guys are feeling okay
we've been going for two and a half
hours probably go for another
another 30 minutes maybe another hour
on this once we get these like steam
jets going
but i think it's about time to get a
kombucha because i am
feeling a little thirsty and we can
always work on
our lava flow texture here to get that
really really nice so i'm gonna keep
working on that
now i'll be right back i'm gonna grab a
drink i'll see you guys in like two
seconds
man burke that is the goal the render
has got to look cooler than the
reference
that's certainly what we're going for
next week i am going to
talk about my process of switching out
this character because i'm going to
photo scan myself in my camping gear
and um make it all sci-fi out and i'm
gonna walk you guys through my process
of that
which i'm very excited for i'm excited
for this whole thing really this is a
quite a blast and a good time it's a
very good time
and art day you are correct the png
sequence is to
retain the alpha information um
in the in the layer so i'm able to just
drop it into the mountain in the
background
now this is a trick that um if you guys
know ian hubert he
is maybe one of blender's very best
artists
and he uses this trick a whole lot he's
constantly doing like
atmospheric smoke stuff in the
background with this trick
looks like this is gonna take a minute
so
let me let me see if this lightning
trick works
and what we need we got to go to tools
we got to go to size and we'll set it to
large because we want high quality
images of lightning that we can drop
over this
maybe this one here this is pretty big
this is not bad but it has like all the
um that's that looks like after effects
this is amazing this is definitely
the vibe here
that's so cool
but it's so tiny that's the issue it's
so tiny
we'll crunch it down
so there's no glow
but we don't want to crunch it so much
that we lose the details
and that's kind of what's happening here
so maybe it's something like that and we
set that to screen
and now we have this as an element
for our lava which that
i mean that totally looks legit to me
that gets like a real natural look for
the lava flow there
and i just want to find like some larger
images
some higher quality images
man lightning is so cool
awesome very large
super high quality so we'll make it
black and white we'll drop the
saturation
and control l will give us our levels
so we crunch that down and i'm really
looking at
the fine detail down here so like this
stuff
i don't want to lose this so
maybe that's as far as i'd go something
like that
and i'm going to go ahead and erase
or just with a black brush is totally
fine let's go ahead and make this raster
able
so renderize that layer or rasterize it
rather and we'll just paint black in
here
we'll take the flow up and the hardness
up
and i just want to get rid of this like
stuff that isn't really lightening or is
that the
it's the lightning behind the trees
and we'll come in here and just clean
this
up a little bit because i'll crunch this
down a little bit further
i'll get rid of this guy these ones that
aren't really tethered
this is just a cool interesting way to
think outside the box
and get a look
so let's try that again
let's actually do a
levels adjustment modifier we'll crunch
that down
until we like it right there
something like that cool
feels good to me
and we'll erase it in the areas where we
don't
want it okay so basically
we can see that it's getting rid of all
this detail down here
we don't want that we just want that
super crunch basically to be up in here
so i'm going to select this little white
box hit ctrl i that's going to invert it
and i'm going to paint in there so i'm
going to paint white
let's see boom yep drop the hardness
and we're going to paint white to give
us that effect
only only in the areas where
we need it because you want to retain
all that detail
so let's be very careful
and we'll drop the opacity
so that feels good um i'm gonna go ahead
and group these guys
and we'll make that editable
set it to screen and we'll flip this
around
and that gets us a nice looking
bit of lava there that's actually pretty
sweet
awesome
very nice i like that a lot
very detailed because of the lightning
so adding the lightning
gave us that look right there
which i'm a huge fan of so let's go
ahead and
duplicate this around to the other
side
just like that and we obviously need to
get rid of like
whatever this logo is
so we can just kind of content aware
fill this out
and that's going to be shift backspace
and you make sure your contents is set
to content aware
and it gets it gets rid of it
immediately it's
basically the greatest thing ever
content aware fill
is the best um i'm also going to
i think that's fine down here as is it
kind of tapers off naturally
so i'm going to save this photoshop
document
and i'll save this image
as our lava map we'll replace it and
we'll see what it looks like here
get this update
so let's store the render buffer
and let's make sure that that lava
texture updates
okay there it goes
and that's the difference that's awesome
yeah the lightning the lightning really
adds
really really added to that it added a
lot of good detail that i think
is super solid so
that's fun that totally worked now after
effects
is still going hard all right that is
quite
the export it maybe didn't need to be at
2k resolution
but we'll place a couple of these around
the scene
and i'll render a new one as we continue
here and see what we get
what's up salumi how you doing
um good to have you man it's been a
minute
yeah we just added some sweet lava on
top of this with this map in photoshop
using images of lightning
and i think it worked i totally think it
worked i love it when that stuff works
out
salumi are you doing a submission
for this environment contest because you
always put out good work man
i really really think you you put out
some good stuff
daniel what's up oh just finished yeah
so we're
we're actually making some elements
in after effects where these are just
action ascend or action
v effects stock footage packs of some
smoke and whatnot
i'm taking this i'm going to throw it on
to some cards
now these have alpha they were exported
with alpha which means you're not going
to see the black
and i'm going to put them back here
behind these rocks to make it look like
the volcano is steaming
so let's go ahead and set this up i'm
just going to make an
octane diffuse material i'll hop in and
we
we just want to give it uh let's see
we don't even need to go into node view
to be honest
we'll go to the diffuse channel we'll
load the image and
we'll find and navigate to our
render output windy smoke we'll hop in
here we'll select one of these we'll hit
open and
we'll click this we'll go to animation
and we'll calculate it so that's all the
frames of this animation
we'll set it to linear i believe is the
way to go on that
i'll try with the i'll try with the
embed for now
and then you want to go to common
or notice editor and animate the preview
so let's go ahead and make a plane
and the plane you need to have the at
the right aspect ratio
so i'm going to do 1920 by
1080 because that is the aspect ratio of
the stock footage that we just rendered
out of after effects
i lied it's 2048 by 1080
so you just need to match that that's
true
2k resolution let's stand it up
and let's see if if this works
all right so that looks horrible um
let's go to the node editor and we'll go
view
frame all all right so i'm select that
it's tri-linear probably do anything
but what we want to do is actually
i should you should be able to hit like
alpha on this
maybe here's what we have to do diffuse
image texture
load our smoke element
and we'll set that to alpha
and we'll also pipe that into the
opacity
and maybe we need to invert this
oh it looks like we had it
so let's let's try this let's try
pushing this all the way back
to the mountain
and we got to flip it upside down
i'm going to turn off our fog because
it's taking up a lot of render juice
and i'm obviously not seeing our smoke
if i scrub forward
i'm still not seeing our smoke so maybe
what we need to do
is throw some color correction on here
and do something with our gamma
there we go i can start to see it now
so maybe we duplicate this and we say
this is just
normal and
this new one is the opacity
so maybe it's
maybe we just need to adjust
there we go okay there we go now this is
working so
i have just the you know the base um
image texture or image sequence in the
diffuse
with no changes i just changed it to
float because it's black and white
and then for the alpha i duplicated it i
set the type to alpha and then i just
boosted the gamma a little bit to give
it
a bit more um to give it a bit more
opaqueness so i can see through it a
little bit more
that looks really good
and it'll be animated so if i hit if i
hit uh
if i hit play
this should be
animating should be animating
um if it's not let's come in here and
double check so the animation we
calculate
now it's being animated we want the same
for the opacity
we go in here animation we animate so
now it's being animated
now i'm not seeing anything because i'm
wondering if
now you're supposed to be seeing stuff
the whole time
hmm
so i set it to range
and it looks like let's see the best way
to tell the difference
so zero it's gone but frame one it's
in okay so maybe this is just a bit of
trial and error guys
maybe we set it to exact
frame
exact second or range okay so range is
working
for some reason
usually usually this works so here
again when i'm trying to problem solve
the fastest way for me to do so is in
just a blank
new scene to see what the heck is going
on
so i'm gonna do that i'm gonna simplify
it and then transfer over what i learned
into the main composition
all right let's do this so
we'll grab an image texture and we'll
load
our png sequence and it looks like but
but let's try and get it animated i
click calculate and it goes away
i don't know why that's the case
all right so that brings it in
why why why is it not animating
do you guys have any ideas
as to why this is not working
let's calculate it and let's just say
200 frames
that's so weird
i wonder if it would work in a
non-octane material
movie start frame 2644.
i think that's why
we'll make sure we want to animate the
preview which
it's not working for some reason but
hopefully in the renderer
there you go it's working it's because
of our movie start frame
that's that's why it wasn't working so
the movie start frame
is in our case
what the movie star frame is referencing
when you're in after effects it's
referencing this number the start frame
2644.
i'm going to set that to zero it should
always be a zero
but for just this one it's 26.44 so
we'll go back
into our main setup here and we'll just
make sure those
uh let's see range exact
frame 2644
fantastic render and now it's actually
working properly so sweet solving
problems
solving problems every day
that's all you gotta do when you're
doing vfx is solve
problems
constantly solving problems
bunny live you had it you had the answer
so now we can move
this card around however we want
and what we want to do is kind of hide
it behind
bits of rock and use it all right so if
i go
something like this let's go ahead and
turn down the intensity of this
light it's just it's too much right now
and we don't need it
so i'm going to take the emissive
texture
and tell it to just hold on for a second
because it's too much
all right so let's take the plane here
i'm gonna go to check camera and hop
out so we can actually see what's going
on
let's see if we can start using the
smoke
to shape out our environment you see how
it's behind
this rock well that's exactly what we
want we want it to be behind this rock
and you can scale this thing up even
more
that's amazing yeah that looks really
cool
so i'm just going to place these all
around um
now i wish there was an easier way to
kind of adjust and offset the timing so
i might have to
make new cards
um to truly offset the timing
so let me
kind of come over here
and uh seb chen yes i am using
a pen in replacement of a mouse it is
the best i absolutely love it
i don't own a mouse um i don't play any
like desktop games i'm mostly playing on
my playstation or my
nintendo switch so i don't really need a
mouse
man that just looks sweet i'm gonna
start rendering another one here it's
that windy smoke that really
really looks nice
and i'm going to render this one at half
resolution because i don't think we need
the full 2k
so best settings you can just take to
go to half
we'll make sure we go png sequence
render output windy smoke
this will be windy smoke 2.
and that should go a lot faster
so i'm going to flip this around
and you'll see them doing this a lot in
video games
um they do this
to get these kind of looks in um
oops let's try that again in different
video games that's how they make like
different atmospheric effects
yeah that's really starting to add now
you want to offset these because you
don't want them to be
really kind of going um you don't want
to be duplicated it's the same reason we
want to break up our tiling is the same
reason you want to offset the timing of
these different smoke bits so i'm going
to duplicate it
and i'll set this one to the start frame
[Music]
instead of 2644 let's offset it by like
i don't know 300 frames 29.44
and we'll apply that to the new card
here
and you should get a different look a
different steam look there
and we can scale it up
and maybe it's not
entirely um
oh that looks so cool
and maybe i'll just offset it by another
300 frames we have a lot of frames to
deal with so
um let's do
32 44.
we definitely make sure that these are
both
not the same here
there we go
and we can do a third one this one could
be
35 44.
and we're just doing this to get
different looks
so let's keep going let's keep
duplicating
and you want these at different depth
amounts so
let's hop in and keep placing these
things
so i'm hitting n and q to turn
off textures and that'll allow me to
you'll see this a little bit more
oh that's awesome that smoke is back
behind the mountain
and let's give that
this guy here we just want to make sure
all of these have different
smoke values
awesome
and we can duplicate and
drop one into this like central little
area
and that looks amazing yeah
that looks super cool so i'm gonna keep
going i'm gonna keep adding this stuff
off
into like the corners and really just
add to the scene and pepper all this
stuff out um
let's get the emission texture going
again
and see what it looks like
and we just want to keep building it up
keep working there you go there's our
second one so we can
we can add that now and get
even different looks so all these cards
we can just keep working on and keep
adding
um so i'll duplicate this and
we'll hop in and i'll name these as a
smoke one
smoke 1.1
smoke 1.2 and this will be
this will be smoke 2.
and we'll switch these out
so we got a completely different look
now and the start frame
if we calculate that should
line up just perfectly
so let's go ahead and duplicate this guy
over here
and we'll drop on smoke 2 to that new
one
okay so smoke 2 needs to be
adjusted somehow unless smoke 2 starts
with nothing really in frame
but okay that's not the case
that actually that's not bad i think
it's just blending in with the
background that's all
and let's go ahead and control drag
smoke 2
over to the right side
and let's see if we can't get it behind
this little crag right here
scale it up move it up
so now it's back here
and we'll control drag smoke too
drop it on and we'll call this guy smoke
2.2
because this is where we're going to
offset it
we'll go 300 frames
and you see that you see how it gets us
this like
this effect in the mountains back here
a foggy atmospheric effect it's exactly
what we're going for
and you just want to break up all these
different rocks with little different
pieces of smoke
i'm very happy with this i think this is
turning out nicely
we'll do 2.3 and we'll do 2.4
so 2.3 will offset another 300 frames
and i'm hoping 300 frames is enough
we can always change it and at the end
of the day we only need 88 frames for
our render
so let's go ahead
and just keep moving this up that'll be
2.3
and we'll move up another one
and that'll be 2.4
that looks so cool
so it's getting there it's certainly
getting there
to this kind of level and it's just
layers and layers and adding different
layers
so i think we have one more small
windy smoke which we'll export here
from after effects png sequence
and we'll go windy smoke
three
and again i think we can do we're okay
with doing uh
half quality there because it's in the
background it's pretty far away
3d what graphics card am i using i am
using an rtx quadro 6000
which is allowing me to really add a
bunch of crap to my scene
it's great it has 24 gigs of vram alone
just on the one card
um you can see it down here i've got 24
gigs of vram and i've used 2.7 so far
um it's a fantastic card and it's
allowed me to create these larger scenes
which i really hadn't had a chance to
before
because i was on i was on a gtx 1070
before this
so it is blowing my mind
[Music]
it's pretty incredible so very very
very excited about it nvidia did send it
over
a few months ago um
so yeah it's been cool
um you go i'm not quite sure the
difference
between the rtx rtx 2070 and the quadro
rtx 4k
but i think you can go to
a website that like allows you to
compare cards
um let's just say like rtx
quadro versus um
like rtx 20 30
80 or something and oh it's benchmark
yeah okay so you can go to benchmark
and compare like the different
cards and everything this guy right here
and it'll tell you all the stats between
the two cards
so i was using and i was using a gtx
1070 it wasn't even a ti
and i'm currently on a rtx
quadro 6000
so it looks like this card the 6000 is
140 percent
better than the gtx 1070. so what you're
saying
comparing uh the rtx 2070
to the quadro okay so the rtx
let's do rtx 2070
nvidia rtx 2070 compared to
the quadro
4000
rtx quadro 4000
ah so the rtx 2070 versus the rtx quadro
4000
speed wise is 12 percent better
ah interesting very interesting
so you i mean if you have the rtx 2070
versus the quadro
4k it looks like you're in a better
position just a little bit by just uh
just a touch
so that's that's cool to know it's very
good to know but yeah this is a great
website it helps you compare different
cards and everything
um but yeah let's keep adding
different little smoky bits i like this
second one
smoke 2 is a bit more subtle so i think
i'm going to add
some smoke 2 elements over on the left
side
of the frame
and i feel like i could use a couple
more
oh i could definitely use one back
behind there
so let's just take this guy and get it
back in there
to separate
these little bits
and there's the third one it's done so
i'll ctrl drag smoke 2
and we'll make smoke 3.
and we'll load these guys
and calculate
and let's go ahead and draw a drop smoke
3 onto that new guy
and we'll make all of our different
versions for smoke 3 to give us
a bit of randomness
do
awesome
so i'll bring this forward scale it down
and try and fit it between some of these
mountains here
as many different areas you can break up
the better
you
that looks very cool yeah
i'm happy with this i'm wondering if we
can do any stuff
on the mountain itself so if we can come
back here
and start doing cards on the mountain
awesome yeah that looks super cool
sweet yeah that's looking that's looking
really nice
i'm very happy with this i
kind of want to do a quick test render
and see what that looks like
so let's see let's lock the aspect ratio
we'll go 640 by 270
all frames 24 frames a second
and let's save this out
we'll do iterations and we'll call this
v1
and we'll see what we get um
but that has been that has been a fun
stream i think that
really turned out it looks super nice um
this should go really fast but i'm gonna
hang out with you guys for the next 5-10
minutes while this renders
answer any questions you might have and
we'll take a look at the final product
and see what it looks like
yeah so am i gonna have a big cloud
behind the mountain maybe some
volumetrics uh to have some cool volume
illumination yeah definitely
again we're going for this we're going
for this vibe so i'm really happy with
what i have so far on this mountain i
might keep adding to it throughout the
week
um but i definitely need to get
the sky back here looking right and the
clouds and everything around this area
looking correct so i'll probably do
i might do some fog volumes but i might
honestly
build out the sky um
like in after effects and bring that in
after the fact i like this png
sequence um with like cards
in cinema 4d i think it's really
powerful so
i might do a little bit of that with
some fog in the foreground here
up in this area i think that could be
sweet and i also might just tweak it a
little bit in after effects after i
render too
um to get the right look of the fog but
you know these trees are gonna go in
eventually i'll put some crows in here i
do want to have some birds flying around
up here i think that would be absolutely
incredible
so maybe that's just me going outside
and filming some birds and
comping them in the same exact way i'm
doing with these
smoke cards um
the only question mark for me is on like
the illuminated smoke up here because i
don't
i don't quite know how to do super nice
smoke simulations um i could comp it
certainly but
i don't know i'm going to figure that
one out i'm going to certainly have to
figure that one out it's gonna be tough
but it's okay i think regardless of what
happens
this render is gonna look super sweet
yeah i'm excited i'm very excited for
this
so how's everybody coming on their
renders are you guys doing okay do you
guys have any questions
are you guys entering the contest are
you just starting it's totally okay
i have only worked on this for
the last three streams this stream last
week and the week before that
so i haven't had all the time in the
world
um certainly not
oh this is cool
yeah you get a little bit of a little
bit of animation back here i think this
one's a little fast
stuff in the background you want it to
be um if it's in the back you want it to
be moving slowly
that's how you know this thing looks big
because
when you have this quick moving smoke it
looks fast so i'm going to go back in
there and maybe slow some of that stuff
down just a bit
but i think it's looking pretty darn
cool
yeah i'll probably use some stock vdb
assets
drop those in i think that'll look nice
lobap how can
i start earning money from c4d when you
reach a good level
from sites like freelancer um
so you know i've i've started
freelancing
back in 2000
2000
2007 is i think when i started
freelancing
i was young and i just made one good
relationship i made one good connection
with a guy his name's joe cornell he
owns
synapse effects and they are a one-stop
shop
for anything practical pyro
any like weather atmosphere fog
blood and gore
pyrotechnics fire you know he's a guy
doing that and he
from time to time took on some web
clients who had
some vfx needs or some graphical needs
and i helped him out with that
he was the first guy to really help me
with um
with the freelance world and i think
once you make a good connection
keep that connection okay and how to
make the first connection yeah i guess
you said
sites like freelance or um
[Music]
i know there's a website called like uh
shoot it's one where you can like post
your work
um give me two seconds and i'm going to
get you
the name of this website it's good for
freelancing
uh fiverr i think is the name of it
fiverr
so you can offer your services on fiverr
and business is all about the
relationship so as long as you continue
in harbor
not harbor um uh basically
yeah just make sure it's a good
relationship keep working on it
keep adding to it and make them happy
you got to certainly come to a point
where like
you don't want to give the client
everything and bend to their every will
but you do want to make sure that you
guys agree
whatever you agree to in the beginning
um
you get them in the end and
you'll build a nice relationship with
that client and they'll come back to you
they'll certainly come back to you so
keep it up yeah
hugo or hugo says art station is also
good
personally i don't know but i do know a
lot of game developers and
concept artists uh and game guys are on
art station they're posting other stuff
there so it's a good place to
keep your work as a portfolio most
definitely
but this has been fun everybody this has
been a lot of fun
um i'm very excited
about all these renders that are coming
in so far there's six renders that have
come in
and they're all really cool so keep it
up i'm really looking forward to seeing
everybody's
this top 20 thing it doesn't it's not
going to work unless you guys turn in
your awesome renders
and i really want this final product to
be super sick so i'm counting on you
guys
to keep working work hard and i promise
you will you will be rewarded
um whether it be with a new graphics
card a new ssd
uh you know some flash drives or if i'm
sending you prints i'm you're going to
be rewarded
physically in some sort of way but also
um
you're gonna be rewarded in the sense
that you took on a long-term project and
completed it and you're gonna feel good
about that
most certainly
seb chen yo yeah dude pinterest man it's
great
i'm glad it's now my most favorite
inspiration concept source which i
always had a problem finding before yeah
dude
pinterest is great you build up those
boards and really really kind of tweak
um those looks that you're going for it
helps with inspiration
so i'm glad very very happy that that
the first stream did it for you man
um let's try bringing that down
where are you picture viewer
cool so we got a little look at the
smoke back there that looks awesome
so there's this one like quick moving
one back here that we gotta figure out
but that's certainly it like that's the
vibe they're all kind of placed back
there
um i think they can all move a little
slower probably half
speed maybe this one quarter speed most
definitely
but i'm very very happy with this look i
think it's awesome
ah so cool i've never done this before
and i'm really glad it turned out
that's awesome yeah i gotta keep working
on my lava i think i
maybe get a lava river coming down here
or something in the foreground but
i think that'll be a good time dude i've
heard the joseph seed comment
so many times i got a shave no i don't
gotta shave i need to get a haircut
that's what i need man
and don't worry we're gonna add
vignettes we're gonna color correct the
crap out of this
if you can make it look good without
color correction
then my god it's gonna look nice with
some color correction i promise you
yay i'm super glad that you guys are
enjoying all these
um jacob are you saying if you don't
have c4d experience should you start in
blender
it's really up to you man at the end of
the day um
but blender is free it allows you to
jump in and learn for free so
maybe that is a good place to start and
then when you're ready to
uh maybe spend some money
on a subscription service i know max on
switched over to something like that
recently
you can hop onto that i love cinema 4d
i'm never gonna switch over
um yeah it's it's
it's one of my favorite programs ever so
if but if you guys like blender there's
nothing wrong with that definitely look
in the blender if you're trying to get
into the 3d world
it's definitely the most successful way
to do so
emil thanks for joining appreciate you
what am i thinking for the sky
definitely some storm clouds absolutely
definitely some storm clouds um
you know i'm going for this this
reference that i put together in the
first
stream volume one is on building concept
art
now there's a lot of um
[Music]
references here in the qixel
rebirth trailer um
a lot of good references for the sky
in here
so it's very foggy
but there you can see there's some
clouds back there
certainly and they're doing the same
trick here they're doing the same trick
with those cards
for fog like this stuff is definitely a
fog layer
all that stuff is a is a fog layer
[Music]
um
yeah so they're they're doing they're
doing things like maybe this
is this is certainly a brighter sky
i definitely want to go for more of a
stormy look um
and then maybe have like
some sunlight blasting the foreground
which i think is always a really cool
look
i love that look so much like there's a
guy on
art station his name is
um
eton zana
and he was the lead i believe the lead
concept designer for the last of us
too but he's got this image here
is exactly i'm talking about you have a
foggy
dark kind of stormy background and scene
but you have these little streaks
of sunlight that come through the storm
which i love
i love that look so i'm definitely going
to try and get that kind of vibe going
towards the end of
of the process here and eton he's great
you definitely got to check out his work
i take a lot of inspiration from him
um like this is just beautiful
absolutely beautiful and he gives this
whole process down here too which is
sweet
looks like this is last of us yep this
is his work on last of us
absolutely beautiful absolutely
beautiful you can tell there's
inspiration here that i'm going for here
it's kind of in that similar
um foggy dark uh
wet kind of vibe which is super sick
yeah atonsana it's pronounced or it's
spelled
e-y-t-a-n it looks like eaton but it's
aton
eton zana
and thoughts on real-time ray tracing
thanks to rtx dude of course
i mean what else do you want to know
like that sounds great
i'm excited i'm still working on unreal
engine i haven't given up on unreal
i've just been doing a lot of c4d
streaming these days so um
yeah you know it'll be a good time
i'm excited for next year very very
excited for next year
but guys um please keep up the good work
knock out those submissions it's really
going to make the top 20
video something special i want it to be
something special
so i'm looking to you guys counting on
you guys
to deliver some awesome stuff no
pressure no pressure
i'm just excited to you know collaborate
with everybody and put something cool
together
so guys i'm going to bounce i'm going to
grab some food
chill out for a little bit but you guys
are awesome thank you so much for
everybody's help
and uh i'll see you guys next week it's
next week is going to be our final
stream
um for this contest right here
and then i'm going to be announcing the
winners on november 7th
okay so hang on to your butts
keep cranking and uh
post in the parallel dimensions work in
progress channel it's on the discord
in the discord server um down below
so definitely join that if you guys want
to uh
want to keep up with everybody's process
and everything
and you know in the meantime if you guys
are looking for other ways to support i
do have
an hdri pack a warzone hdri pack that i
put out
earlier this year i do sell photography
prints both of those links are in the
description below as well
um yeah check them out i'm going to send
i'm going to be sending out a batch of
prints this week
i had some uh some some good
big ones printed out so i'm actually i'm
probably gonna go pick those up
today but y'all you've been awesome
thank you so much for joining me i hope
you guys learned a thing or two
i know i sure did so i'll see you guys
next
saturday same place same time peace out
y'all have a good one